- Did you order the code red?
- I don't care, I didn't
care, it's awesome.
- Did you order the code red?
- You're goddamn right I did.
- Yes.
We both know you can't shout in court.
The witnesses aren't gonna shout,
the lawyers aren't gonna shout,
but it's so good.
- It's so good.
(gentle music)
There's always been one legal movie
I've never wanted to do
because I don't have an
expertise in military law,
"A Few Good Men."
- Did you order the code red?
- But, I called in some air support.
The scowl owl to my legal eagle, Spencer.
- Devin, good to be here.
- Spencer, in my
experience on the internet,
it seems like everyone has an expertise
in military law
and military tactics.
What makes you qualified to talk about
"A Few Good Men?"
- Well, I suppose it might be
that I was a judge advocate
in the Marine Corps
for a few years.
- Okay, so you were a judge advocate.
But it's not like you saw combat
or anything, right?
- Well, in addition to that,
I was an artillery officer
and a joint terminal attack
controller in the Marines.
- Yeah, sure, but then you retired
to some cushy big firm job, right?
- Well, in addition to all that,
I'm also a Deputy District Attorney
on Pacific Northwest where I
prosecute major felony crimes.
- Okay, internet, if you take issue
with anything Spencer says,
please send your objections to
Spencer (beep) at gmail.com.
All right, let's do it.
Let's get into "A Few Good Men."
- Let's do it.
- That doesn't sound right.
(Spencer laughing)
I assume the Marines are
doing this all day long.
- You wake up 4:30 in the morning,
0430, maybe you brush your teeth,
definitely gonna shave,
and then you immediately go out
and of 16 hours of silent drill.
This is what makes us
the premiere fighting force in the world.
(Devin laughing)
And Devin, if it's not clear,
this is the military equivalent
of break dance fighting.
- Keep the eye on (indistinct).
- I'm just gonna point out here
that it's pretty common actually
that the silent drill platoon
does their morning workout
right in front of the JAG
headquarters in Washington D.C.
There's a synergistic relationship
between the two entities,
and it's historical and hard to describe,
we'd have to do a whole
different video about it.
- Now, they're introducing
the judge advocate
general corps, what is that?
- So, in most branches
of the U.S. military
we have separate corps
which are made up of
officers who are lawyers,
and those are the judge
advocate general corps
and the JAG corps.
- Captain, I appreciate you seeing me
on such short notice.
- Would you like to sit down?
- I'm fine sir.
- Have a seat.
- Okay.
- These are members of the Navy,
and we're dealing with a
potential criminal situation
that happened on a Marine
corps base with Marines.
- This actually takes
place aboard a Naval Base,
Naval Base Guantanamo.
And so because it's a Naval base,
ultimately the Navy has authority
over what's happening on board that base.
- Okay, so in case you don't
remember the movie here,
what happens is a solider is killed
during a hazing process.
Two Marines are accused,
Dawson and Downey.
And this whole movie is
more or less going to hinge
on whether these two soldiers
were ordered to do this hazing process,
the code red,
or whether they did it themselves,
on their own initiative.
- And Devin, I'm just gonna interrupt
you real quick,
before your comment section overflows
with really angry Marines,
you just described them as soldiers,
and that's about as worse a
sin as you could possibly do.
- Oh no, oh God.
- Worse than murder,
worse than espionage.
- Worse than joining (indistinct).
- You do not call Marines soldiers.
You just don't do it.
- All right, how should
I have referred to them?
- Just refer to them as Marines.
- I knew that was gonna be the answer.
- God's children.
God's awful little children.
- What would you call someone in the Navy?
- Sailor.
- Oh, crap, okay, all right.
Would you call someone
in the Army a solider?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- And then you call them
airman in the AirForce,
and then the coast guard,
still working on that.
I think they call themselves guardians
or guards.
It's not guardsman,
'cause that would be National Guard.
So I think it's guardians.
I think they call themselves guardians.
- [Devin] Okay.
- Excuse me, sorry I'm late.
- Danny, I know you
don't have a good excuse,
so I won't force you to
come up with a bad one.
- Thank you, sir.
- First one's for you.
Guess you're moving up in the world.
Requested by division.
Guantanamo Bay, Cuba.
A Marine Corporal named Dawson
illegally fires a round from his weapon.
PFC William Santiago
threatens to rat on Dawson,
Dawson and PFC Louden Downey
go into Santiago's room,
tie him up, stuff a rag down his throat,
attending physician says the rag
was treated with some kind of toxin.
In the meantime go and see
Lieutenant Commander JoAnne
Galloway, internal affairs.
- Okay, so does it make
any sense in this context
that he's going to work
with internal affairs,
the Demi Moore character?
- So, to the extent that there's something
called internal affairs in this movie,
I've never heard of it before.
Maybe it exists,
but the reality of a situation is
the way that the military works
everyone is internal affairs all the time.
(Devin laughing)
- One of the people you'll
be seeing down there
is the Barrack CO Colonel Nathan Jessep,
I assume you've heard of him.
- Who hasn't?
- He's been in the papers lately,
he's expected to be appointed
director of operations of
National Security Council.
- Really?
- Okay, now I can chime in on this one.
How often do you hear about
a colonel in the news in general,
unless they have committed
some horrible crime?
I mean the answer is basically never.
There's no reason why anyone
would have heard of the
Jack Nicholson character,
Colonel Nathan Jessep at this point.
- I'll get them to drop the conspiracy
and conduct unbecoming, 12 years.
- So I think it's importunate to say here
the conduct unbecoming,
this is really the first instance
that we see it in this movie.
We are dealing with a lance corporal
and a private.
We don't have a lot of
expectations of conduct
when it comes to lance
corporals and privates.
We kind of expect them to
do really stupid stuff,
it's just that we expect their
non-commissioned officers
and their officers to deal with it.
- They're just children, Mr. Simpson.
- The unfortunate reality is
if that charge did exist,
every single Marine under
the rank of corporal
would be in a lot of trouble.
(Devin laughing)
- Commander, do you have some
sort of jurisdiction here
that I should know about?
- My job is to make sure
that you do your job.
I'm special council for internal affairs,
so my jurisdiction's
pretty much in your face.
- But that's what I wanna know,
what is internal affairs
supposed to be doing
in the context of this movie?
- No one knows the
answer to that question.
(Devin laughing)
- All right.
- No one knows.
- Tell your friend not
to get cute down there,
the Marines in Guantanamo are fanatical.
- That doesn't make any sense.
- No, that makes no sense at all.
There is no reason why the Marines
in Guantanamo Bay, Cuba,
would be fanatical.
The only fanatics really are probably
the entire base of Camp
Lejeune in North Carolina,
as well as Camp Horno
and Camp Pendelton where
no one can hear you scream.
- Yeah, that doesn't make any sense.
This is peace time,
and there aren't any
terrorists at Guantanamo,
this is before the war on terror.
- Not just that,
this is after the Cold War.
This film was made in 1992,
if they're fanatical,
they're fanatically bored.
- I'm willing to provide you information
about illegal fence line shooting
that occurred the night of August the 2nd.
I wanna know what we're
going to do about this.
- I think Santiago should be transferred
off the base immediately.
- He's that bad, huh?
Transfer Santiago.
Let's transfer the whole
squad off the base.
Let's, on second thought, Windward.
Let's transfer the whole
Windward division off the base.
- I can watch Jack
Nicholson chew the scenery
all day long.
It's just, it's a master
class in ridiculous acting,
and I absolutely love it.
Yeah, but sort of like Tim Burton's joker
in a colonel's uniform, it's amazing.
- So code red is a
disciplinary engagement,
what's that mean exactly?
- Sir, a Marine falls out of line,
it's up to the men in his
unit to get him back on track.
- What's a garden variety code red?
- Sir?
- Harold, you say sir,
and I turn around and look for my father.
Danny, Daniel, Cappy.
- Absolutely not.
(Devin laughing)
Absolutely not.
Under no circumstances it that okay.
No, just no.
Any enlisted Marine is
gonna refer to an officer
as sir or ma'am, period, end of story.
This, this actually, I will say this,
this perfectly encapsulates
Lieutenant Kaffee's character.
He has no concept of wearing the uniform.
He has no concept of what
it means to be an officer.
He has no concept of what it means
being in the military.
- Did you assault Santiago
with the intent of killing him?
- No, sir.
- What was your intent?
- To train him, sir.
- Okay, but here's the thing,
this is the crux of the movie.
If you only intended to beat him up,
and he died,
that's still one of the
varieties of homicide.
- Yeah, you're engaging
incredibly reckless conduct,
and you're causing the death
of someone else through assault.
So it is, it's not a great line here.
- What do you know about code reds?
- Before you go getting
yourself into trouble tomorrow,
I think you should know
the platoon commander,
Lieutenant Jonathan Kendrick,
held a meeting with the men,
and specifically told them
not to touch Santiago.
- Are you familiar with a code red?
- So this, I'll say this,
that term, code red,
I think that may either have been
invented for the purpose of this movie,
or it was a term that
was used back in the day.
Nowadays we just use the term hazing.
And hazing is a pretty big deal,
and the Marine Corps and other branches
have been working really hard
at taking hazing out of the equation.
- Have you ever ordered a code red?
- I have never,
I mean I've done-
- Have you ordered a code red?
- I did what was required of me.
- Have you ever ordered a code red?
- You're goddamn right I did.
(Devin laughing)
- Lieutenant Kendrick,
may I call you John?
- No, you may not.
- Have I done something to offend you?
- No, I like all you Navy boys.
Every time we gotta go someplace to fight,
you fellas always give us a ride.
- Well that's a pretty classic one,
well done to the script writer.
The U.S. Navy, the U.S.
Marine Corps taxi service.
(Devin laughing)
- There was a platoon
meeting on September 6th
at four in the afternoon.
Lieutenant Kendrick says that
he gave strict instructions
that nothing was to happen to Santiago.
- Ma'am, that's correct.
- And what happened then?
- Lieutenant Kendrick
came to our room, ma'am.
Lieutenant Kendrick ordered us
to give Santiago a code red.
- Okay, so the way that they're
describing a code red here
sounds super illegal.
It sounds like hazing,
and I assume there are rules against that.
Are Marines required to
follow illegal orders,
assuming that that is an illegal order?
- No.
So this is where it becomes complicated.
The reality is it's a defense to say
I was ordered to do something,
but there are exceptions
and the exception is it's not a defense
if you either know that
the order is unlawful,
or a person of ordinary sense
and understanding would have known
the orders to be unlawful.
And now to be clear it's not a person,
you're not grabbing
someone off the street,
it's someone in that culture,
a Marine, a solider, what have you.
- You're not permitted to question orders.
- Then what's the secret, huh?
What are the magic words?
I give orders every day,
nobody follows them.
- We have softball games
and marching bands,
they work at a place where
you have to wear camouflage
or you might get shot.
- By the Cubans?
- Yeah.
- I need you, you're better
at research than I am,
and you know how to prepare a witness.
- I mean any law student should know
how to do legal research,
and any trial lawyer should know
how to prep a witness.
- What is he really saying
that his strengths are?
I mean what is he saying?
- Talking good.
He can talk good.
- His strengths are talking good.
I don't really know what his
strengths are at this point,
except that he's Tom Cruise.
- [Devin] Well that is a big plus there.
- This is our defense.
Intent.
No one can prove there
was poison on the rag.
Code red, they're common
and accepted in Guantanamo Bay.
The order.
A, Kendrick gave it,
b, they had no choice but to follow it.
- They're creating a theme
of their defense.
They have three different holes
that they're trying to poke
in the prosecution's case,
and they're taking deeper dives
into the strategy of each one
so that they can fold that
into the rest of the trial.
It's not terrible.
- Right.
And the reality is if they're only charged
with pre-meditated murder,
and that's the only theory
that the government is
going with on this one,
then focusing on that intent
could be a home run.
They might be winning on that one.
Depending of course on
lesser included offenses
like unpremeditated
murder and man slaughter
and what have you.
But then focusing on the code red
and the order is also really important
exactly for that reason
that following orders can
sometimes be a defense.
And if they can say code
reds are super common
down in Guantanamo Bay,
then they may be able to say they thought
it was a legal order.
And any ordinary person down there
would have thought it was legal.
- I've been trying to track down
a Lieutenant Colonel
Matthew Andrew Markinson.
- Doctor, was there any
sign of external damage?
- [Doctor] No.
- No scrapes?
- [Doctors] No.
- No cuts?
- [Doctor] No.
- Bruises, broken, bones?
- [Doctors] No.
- Doctor, was there any sign of violence?
- You mean other than the dead body?
- Shit, walk into that every goddamn time.
- So I think this is not
bad cross examination prep,
and it's something that
a lot of lawyers forego.
You gotta red team your own cases
and your own witnesses.
And this is prepping for
the cross examination
of the doctor who's going
to be a hostile witness,
and who doesn't want you to be able
to poke holes in his medical opinion
regardless of whether he
thinks they're innocent or not.
And you can't ask these kind of questions
that just set you up for a softball
for a hostile witness
to just jump all over.
- The accused entered the barracks room
of their platoon mate
PFC William Santiago.
They woke him up, tied his arms
and legs with tape,
forced a rag into his throat.
A few minutes later a chemical reaction
called lactic acidosis caused his lungs
to begin bleeding.
He drowned in this own blood,
and was pronounced dead
at 37 minutes past midnight.
These are the facts of the case,
and they are undisputed.
- All right, so
maybe a slightly argumentative
opening statement,
but he is talking about the things
that he is going to prove
in the course of this trial,
talking about what witnesses
are going to testify to.
And highlighting the fact
that a lot of these facts
are not disputed by either side.
So some of this stuff
is gonna be a slam dunk.
And I like that he's
actually using the lectern
that is between council table,
which is generally where you would be
giving these kinds of things,
not running all over the courtroom,
in the well in front of the jury,
and all that kind of stuff.
- That's right.
The story I just told you-
- And of course now he's
in the well of the court
without permission.
- It's the exact same story
you're gonna hear from Private Downey.
Now Lieutenant Kaffee is gonna try
and pull off a little magic act here.
- And this is where it
starts going off the rails.
When you start talking about
what the defense is gonna do,
and start talking about magic acts
and things like that,
you're losing it because you're no longer
focusing on what you're gonna do,
what you're gonna prove,
and how you're gonna prove this
beyond a reasonable doubt.
Now you're just playing into
the defenses hands essentially.
And when we get to the end,
all the magic in the world
will not have been able
to divert your attention
from the fact that Willy Santiago is dead,
and Dawson and Downey killed him.
- You can get close to the jury,
if that's really what you wanna do,
but invading their personal space,
especially when, as
Kevin Bacon's character
is just a captain,
I saw on that panel
that there are people who outrank him,
and do you really wanna
start getting close to them,
sharing their breathing space,
spittle coming out of your mouth,
and hitting them?
No, you don't.
Give them some breathing room,
be the professional,
and don't do that.
- Lieutenant Kaffee.
- There was no poison on the rag.
- Stand up, dude. (laughing)
- Prove otherwise is futile,
'cause it just ain't true.
When Dawson and Downey went
into Santiago's room that night-
- No, stand, no, no, stop walking.
- It wasn't to kill or harm,
and it wasn't because they
were looking for kicks
on a Friday night,
it's because it was what
they were ordered to do.
Now, out in the real
world that means nothing,
and here at the Washington Navy Yard
it doesn't mean a whole lot more.
But if you're a Marine assigned to
Rifle Security Company
Windward, Guantanamo Bay, Cuba,
you're given an order you follow it
or you pack your bags.
- The most condescending
thing you could say
oh, following orders doesn't
matter in the United States,
but it does when you're in
Guantanamo Bay in peace time.
- Right, because remember the
Marines down in Guantanamo
are fanatical, notoriously so.
Tom Cruise's character is a Navy officer,
and he's speaking in a way that perhaps
Navy officers would,
but remember on that panel are
a bunch of Marines as well,
and they're probably
listening to this thinking
this guy has no idea what
the hell he's talking about.
- Commander, is it possible for a person
to have an affliction,
some sort of condition
which might also speed up
the process of acidosis?
- It's possible.
There would still be symptoms though.
- What kind of symptoms?
- There are hundreds of-
- [Danny] Chest pains?
- Yes.
- Shortness of breath?
- [Doctor] Yes.
- Fatigue?
- Of crouse.
- Doctor, is this your signature?
- Yes it is.
- Would you read your handwritten remarks
at the bottom of the page, please, sir?
- Initial testing negative,
patient complains of chest pains,
shortness of breath and fatigue.
- Getting that witness to
say exactly what he said
at some previous time
is perfect.
- In your professional medical opinion,
was Willy Santiago poisoned?
- Your honor, we renew our objections
to Commander Stone's testimony,
and ask that it be
stricken from the record.
We further ask the court
to instruct the court members
to lend no weight to
this witnesses testimony.
- The objection's overruled, council.
- Your honor, the defense
strenuously objects
and requests an 802 conference
so that his honor might
have an opportunity
to hear discussion before
ruling on this objection.
- The objection of the
defense has been heard
and overruled.
- Move to reconsider.
- Your objection is noted,
the witness is an expert,
and the court will hear his opinion.
- You're not supposed
to object to everything.
You can really seem like the jerk
when you're making this
long speaking objection
that's totally unnecessary,
and it's very clear she's not doing
what everybody else wants her to do
in this particular situation,
strenuously objecting.
- Oh wow, strenuously objecting,
I should take some time to reconsider.
- Including the judge,
who, he's kept a pretty
tight lid on things,
but you do not want to get a judge
into that kind of behavior,
it's only downhill from there.
- Lieutenant, do you
know what a code red is?
- Yes, I do.
- Have you ever ordered a code red?
- No, I have not.
- I mean, so this is
what's really dangerous
about testifying under oath is that
that's probably not true.
He's probably ordered a bunch.
I mean the prior Marine testified
that code reds were
happening all the time.
I would call so many rebuttal witnesses
that are like yeah,
Kendrick told me to order
code red on this day and
this day and this day,
and just destroy his credibility.
- An officer in his position,
he may not be the one
directly ordering code reds
on kind of a day to day basis,
and so the people who are
probably pushing the code reds
in this film at least are the corporals,
the sergeants,
and maybe even some lance corporals.
- Now we object to this
entire line of questioning.
- The government's objection is sustained
Lieutenant Kaffee,
and I would remind you
that you're now questioning
a Marine officer with an
impeccable service record.
- So what?
What?
Why would the judge make that comment?
That is commenting on the evidence
by actually explicitly talking about
this guy's performance evaluations.
Also, how does this judge even know
this Lieutenant's performance evaluations?
There's nothing wrong with
asking pointed questions
of a Marine officer.
I mean they're not gods.
- Can Dawson determine on his own
which orders he's going to follow?
- No, he cannot.
- Why did you go to
Private Santiago's room
on the night of September 6th?
- A code red was ordered
by my platoon commander,
Lieutenant Jonathan James Kendrick.
- Thank you.
- Do Marines have a Fifth Amendment right
not to testify?
- Absolutely.
You have the same right at a
trial, at a Court Marshall.
You do not have to take the stand,
you can if you want to.
The panel members are
going to be instructed
exactly like a civilian criminal trial,
that he has a right to remain silent,
and you can't take into consideration
whether they choose not to testify.
- Did you ever actually
hear Lieutenant Kendrick
order a code red?
- Well, Hal said that-
- Private, did you ever actually hear
Lieutenant Kendrick order a code red?
- No, sir.
- If it please the court,
I'd like to request a recess
in order to confer with my client.
- There's a couple things here.
This is a great example
of why you shouldn't object
every time you can,
because it really puts
an exclamation point
on something happened that I didn't like.
- As far as that private goes,
it actually strengthens his case,
but here's where it gets even worse.
Remember, this is a co-defendant trial.
These two are on trial at the same time.
- They're represented by the same-
- They're represented by
the same defense attorneys,
and right now their interests
materially conflict.
Also, let's talk about witness
preparation for a second.
- You know how to prepare a witness.
(Devin laughing)
- The way in which this most
vital piece of information
can get overlooked so that the first time
that we're hearing about
it is on cross examination.
That is a failure, an absolute failure.
(upbeat music)
- How are you feeling?
- Well, I think Jessep's gonna
have his hands full today.
(Danny laughing)
- Listen, Danny, when
you're out there today,
if you feel like it's not gonna happen,
you feel like he's not gonna say it,
don't go for it,
you could get in trouble.
I'm special council for internal affairs,
and I'm telling you you could
get in a lot of trouble.
- Okay, they keep making an issue here
that he can't go after Colonel Jessep
because it's illegal,
it's attacking a superior officer,
and something terrible is going to happen
if he strenuously cross examines Jessep.
- After falsely accusing a
highly decorated Marine officer
of conspiracy and perjury,
Lieutenant Kaffee will have a long
and prosperous career teaching
type writer maintenance
at the Roccco Clubbo School for Women.
- Is that a thing?
- No, no, I don't know what
the hell this was about.
I think this is, as far as I can tell
some drama generation from Hollywood.
If you have an adverse
witness on the stand,
you are allowed to question them.
- Probably ethically required to-
- Yes.
- Go after them.
- Absolutely.
- The defense calls Colonel Nathan Jessep.
Colonel, when you learned
of Santiago's letter
to the NIS, you had a meeting
with your two senior officers,
is that right?
- Yes.
- At present Colonel Markinson
is dead, is that right?
- Objection.
I'd like to know just what the
defense council is implying.
- Objection, I'd like to know
what opposing council is doing.
Not an objection.
- No, just hey, can you give me
your trial strategy up front please?
- I don't know what it is your honor,
make him tell me.
- Yeah, that's a little known fact
of the uniform code of military justice,
you're required to trade
trial strategy memorandum.
- Oh.
- Yeah, I mean it's weird,
but you know...
- Colonel, at the time of this meeting
you gave Kendrick an order, is that right?
- I told Kendrick to tell his men
that Santiago wasn't to be touched.
- And did you give an order
to Colonel Markinson as well?
- I ordered Markinson to have Santiago
transferred off the base immediately.
- [Danny] Why?
- I felt his life might be in danger
once word of the letter got out.
- Grave danger?
- Is there another kind?
(Devin and Spencer laughing)
- It just occurred to me
why I know the dialogue in
this scene particularly well.
Obviously this is one of the
greatest courtroom scenes
of all time,
however, I know the
dialogue extremely well
because when I was in high school
I would do speech competitions
and every year someone,
the duo category with two people
would do a recreation of
this cross examination,
and so I heard this every weekend
for years on end.
- Was that the first flight off the base?
- The 0600 was the first
flight off the base.
- You flew out to Washington
early this morning,
is that right?
- Yes.
- I notice you're wearing
your class A dress uniform
for your appearance in court today.
- No, he's not wearing
his class A dress uniform.
Those are his service outfits.
Thank you very much though, Mr. Navy Man.
- Did you wear that uniform on the plane?
- I wore utilities on the plane.
- You brought your dress uniform with you?
- Yes.
- Toothbrush, a shaving
kit, change of underwear.
- Your honor.
- Is the Colonel's undewear a matter
of national security?
- Gentleman.
You better get somewhere
fast with this lieutenant.
- Yes, sir.
Colonel.
- He's so clearly laying a
foundation for something,
come on, stop objecting,
let him just get on with it.
- Again, it's not like
this has been dragging on
for 45 minutes.
- Yeah, he's been on the
stand for like 30 seconds.
- [Spencer] Yeah.
- I brought a change of clothes
and some personal items.
- Thank you.
Santiago's barracks room was sealed off
and its contents inventoried.
Four pairs camouflage pants,
three long sleeve kHaki shirts,
three pairs of boots,
four pairs green socks,
three OD green t-shirts-
- Please, the court, is there a question
anywhere in our future?
- I'm wondering why
Santiago wasn't packed.
- A classic way of doing
exactly the same thing,
but with even more power
would be to lay the foundation
for the document that he's reading.
Also, I don't think he's
entered that document
into evidence.
But let's assume he did.
Giving it to the witness
and say read this section.
- You want the witness to be saying
the words you want them to say.
- Yep.
Yeah, exactly.
- Your honor, these are
the telephone records
from Getmo for September 6th,
and these are 14 letters
that Santiago wrote in nine months
requesting, in fact
begging for a transfer.
- I guess it's not in evidence,
we're just gonna have to
take your word for it.
(Spencer laughing)
- The fact is there was
no transfer ordered,
Santiago wasn't going anywhere,
isn't that right, Colonel?
- Objection, your honor,
it's obvious Lieutenant Kaffee's
intention this afternoon
was to smear a high ranking Marine officer
in the desperate hope
the mere appearance of impropriety
will win him points
with the court members-
- That is not an objection.
It's a speaking objection,
but it has no basis whatsoever,
as far as I can tell.
And also, you're telling the jury
that he's scoring points
against your witness.
This objection, this witness
is being torn to shreds
your honor, we need to put a stop to it.
No, stop it.
- Now it's my recommendation, sir,
that Lieutenant Kaffee be
reprimanded for his conduct,
and the witness be excused
with the court's deepest apologies.
- The defendant's rights
not withstanding of course.
(Devin laughing)
- And let's just execute
the defendants your honor.
I've had enough of this trial
and due process.
- Lieutenant Kendrick
ordered the code red,
didn't he?
Because that's what you told
Lieutenant Kendrick to do.
- Object-
- And when it went bad
you cut these guys loose.
- Your honor.
- You had Markinson sign
a phony transfer letter.
You doctored the log book.
- Yeah, and now we're badgering
and being argumentative.
- Did you order the code red?
- You don't have to answer that question.
- I'll answer the question.
You want answers?
- I think I'm entitled.
- [Nathan] You want answers.
- I want the truth.
- You can't handle the truth.
You don't want the truth,
because deep down in places
you don't talk about at parties
you want me on that wall.
You need me on that wall.
- The fence at Guantanamo
is probably a really sleepy place.
- Yeah, about as sleepy as
a posting as you can get.
I mean, imagine that he was
a Marine Security Guard Commander
at one of these nuclear bases in Seattle
or something like that.
Using this exact same language-
- You want me on that chain link fence.
- That's right.
- You need me in front of
that nuclear power plant.
- Don't get me wrong,
it's important work,
it needs to be done,
but the stakes are not this high.
- Deep down inside
you need me to guard the 7-Eleven.
- I don't give a damn what
you think you are entitled to.
- Did you order the code red?
- I don't care, I don't
care, it's awesome.
- Did you order the code red?
- You're goddamn right I did.
- Yes.
We both know you can't shout in court.
The witnesses aren't gonna shout.
The lawyers aren't gonna shout.
But it's so good.
- It's so good.
- There's a reason why this is a classic,
and it's that.
- Jack Nicholson is in this movie
for five minutes.
The movie is two and a half hours long,
he';s in the movie for like five minutes,
and it's the greatest acting
role, I think, of all time.
I think there's an argument for that.
- I mean reasonably, I
think you watch this movie
for this scene.
(Devin laughing)
I mean really it's a
classic because of this.
- It's amazing.
No notes.
- But, again, what happens here?
At this point he may invoke
his right to remain silent
and what happens with the
rest of the Court Marshall?
- I have a suggestion,
A Few Good Men 2: A Few Better Men.
- If we can do Top Gun Two,
we can do A Few Good Men Two.
- Okay, so we both agree
it may not be realistic
but this movie rules.
But we are still going to
give this movie a grade
for legal realism.
(bright music)
Spencer, take it away,
how realistic is it?
- You know, this is a
tough subject matter.
Military justice is not
what most people know
or understand.
I'm just gonna go ahead and say,
I'll give it an A minus.
I mean it's not perfect,
but it's pretty dang close,
and they get a lot of
little details right.
- Yeah, I agree.
This movie has it's flaws,
but it frigging rules.
And another thing that rules
is being able to watch a
longer version of this video,
which you can do with today's sponsor,
Nebula and Curiosity stream.
On Nebula my videos always come out early,
with zero ads.
And I release exclusive
content all the time,
like the director's cut of this video
that you're watching right now,
a new video on things people misunderstand
about the Constitution,
why NFTs are bad for creators,
anti-slap laws,
and my first full length documentary
"Bad Law Words Good,"
which is honestly hilarious.
All of this content can
only be found on Nebula.
In fact, my friends post tons
of exclusive content too,
like Real Engineer;s entire D-day series
and half as interesting crime spree,
where they try to break as
many silly laws as possible
across the United States.
Now all of this exclusive content
is only on Nebula which you can
get for free with Curiosity stream.
And by the way, we've been
developing Nebula like crazy.
Nebula now has apps for
IOS, Android, Apple TV,
Roku, Fire TV and Android TV.
My fellow creators and I
really care about Nebula,
and we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity stream
because they are the go to source
for the best documentaries
and long form educational
content on the internet.
And they even have an entire section
devoted to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the stuff on Curiosity stream.
Now the best way to get access to Nebula
and all the incredible content
is through the amazing Curiosity
stream Nebula bundle deal.
With it's current sales price
of less than $15 per year
to get access to both sites.
And to be clear that Nebula
subscription is not a trial,
it's free for as long as you're
a Curiosity stream member.
There just isn't a
better deal in streaming,
where you get two great streaming sites
with content that you'll
actually watch and enjoy
for less than $15 per year
at the current sales price.
And what's more,
signing up will actually help countless
independent educational creators
beyond just LegalEgale.
So sign up now by clicking on the button
that's on screen right now
or you can click on the link
that's in the description.
It's a great way to sort
educational content,
and get tons of exclusive content
that you'll actually love.
So click on the link
that's on screen right now.
Or you can click on
this playlist over here
with all my other YouTube videos,
so click on this playlist,
or I'll see you in court.